foreign
[Music]
yesterday was a big day for
performatively emotional displays by hen
pact men during the January 6th hearing
uh one man after another took turns
bawling his eyes out weeping openly and
without shame
the most grotesque and nauseating
spectacles came as always from the
politicians here is representative Adam
Schiff getting choked up for unclear
reasons
we deem elections illegitimate merely
because they didn't go our way rather
than trying to do better the next time
and God help us
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born in another country or
they don't look like us
and
God help us
but I have faith
because of folks like you
and uh Adam I didn't expect this would
be quite so much later but it must be an
Adam thing today
uh
but I'm so grateful to all of you and
with that Mr chairman I yield back
uh he's got to work on his acting a
little bit I appreciate the timing so he
timed his emotional breakdown for when
he mentioned bigotry
no that's why we have to be nicer to
people who don't look like us
it's a bigotries
so upsetting to me
um so he he he timed it well but I the
the acting needs a little bit of work he
wasn't the only Adam to carry on this
way Adam kinzinger a republican sobbed
even louder it was an is an inspiring
moment of bipartisan emasculation let's
watch that
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
to my colleagues on the committee
thank you to our Witnesses uh I never
expected a day to be quite as emotional
for me as it has been I've talked to a
number of you and gotten to know you
I think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and you know you talk
about the impact of that day
but you guys won
you guys help
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetorics
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple
let's define the truth
and it's to ensure accountability
sorry I'm getting a little emotional too
well misty-eyed now it goes without
saying that neither of these men have
shed any tears as we discussed earlier
for any of the victims of any of the
horrific BLM riots last year police
officers were bashed over the head with
bricks beat attacked berated this is all
on video uh their precincts were burned
to the ground a retired police officers
murdered in Cold Blood and left for dead
in the street neither of the crying
atoms have ever shed any tears
for those officers by the way that
should be a band name the crying atoms
um that's because their tears are fake
and manipulative fake and manipulative
tears from anyone are disgraceful but
from a man even more so
even leaving aside the rank dishonesty
here
this is also part of a larger problem
a symptom of an endemic disease
the fact that grown men will now cry to
get what they want like my
eight-year-old daughter
only shows again that masculinity is in
a dire state in this culture
there was a time when that sort of
display would have been considered
embarrassing and weak
but now we're meant to take a man
seriously when he cries in front of us
even more seriously if anything
I think this is wrong to put it mildly
and I've said so many times I reiterated
this point on Twitter yesterday this is
what I wrote simply I said um men should
not cry in public it is unmannly and
dishonorable rare exceptions can be made
to this rule but we make far too many
exceptions
and the exceptions are pretty obvious a
loved one dies your child is born your
bride is walking down the aisle at your
wedding
um in the latter two cases a dignified
tier or two may be acceptable but please
don't turn the faucet on okay there's no
reason to go overboard don't try to
prove a point
um other exceptions Can Be Imagined
we've talked about some of them before
perhaps for example you're saying
goodbye to your family before embarking
on a three-year Voyage to Mars
maybe you're watching the end of the
movie Rudy
aside from those rare occurrences
the point is that men
should comport themselves with a certain
level of stoicism and dignity learning
to control their emotions and projecting
an image of strength of someone who is
composed and in control
yeah it's possible to go overboard to go
overboard in that direction becoming an
emotionless robot entirely unaffected by
suffering your own or anyone else's
but there aren't very many men in our
society who are at any risk of falling
into that trap
the the problem in most cases lies way
at the other end of the spectrum
men today are encouraged to put their
emotions on display at all times to be
vulnerable to be soft and feminine and
gentle
men are encouraged to be women in other
words
in fact some of the responses to my
tweet were pretty enlightening lots of
people of course were scoffing at the
opinion that I expressed even though
it's an opinion shared by most people in
the world whether they'll say it out
loud or not most women naturally want a
Man Who Will Comfort them when they cry
they don't want to be doing most of the
comforting
I'm not a woman myself so I will allow
the ladies to correct me on this point
but I can't imagine that most single
women are searching for the kind of man
who will break down in tears at the
slightest disappointment or setback
few women I'm guessing dream of the sort
of man who will come home from work
tears dripping down his cheeks sobbing
and saying I just had a really bad day
Hank at the office was super rude I'm so
frustrated
I would also theorize that the typical
woman wouldn't marry a man at all if she
knew that he'd be the type to shake her
awake in the middle of the night
teary-eyed and trembling and saying I
just heard a noise outside can you go
out and check I'm so scared
few women want men who are like this
few boys want to grow into men like this
and yet our culture produces men like
this
this may not be something that the
average person desires but it is the
agenda all the same
an agenda shared by for example a woman
named Rachel barabow she's not any great
cultural Force by any means but she is a
former sportscaster turned it seems into
some kind of motivational speaker for
students and young men I know of her
existence because she tweeted at me in
response to my thoughts about men crying
and she said two words shut up yep I've
got my sassy pants on today we are
changing the narrative on what
masculinity means despite what this guy
says
now again this is not any any any kind
of a person of any great importance but
there is something so apt about this
here is a woman
who likely doesn't represent the views
of most women we should know
but a woman all the same telling me a
man to shut up on the subject of
masculinity and to defer to her
expertise
she not only a woman but a person who
uses the phrase sassy pants has decided
that she should be in charge of changing
the narrative on masculinity
as for me a man a husband a father of
four I have to pipe down and allow her
to dictate terms
sadly many men have decided to obey
these kinds of Demands from these kinds
of women
our culture has indeed allowed women to
take the lead even to the extent of
defining masculinity
we see this in our schools and our
churches
in Hollywood and media
we live in an increasingly feminine
world
though ironically men are once again
reasserting their dominance by
identifying as women and bringing
Everything full circle it is a confused
situation to say the least
now into this confusion as a way of
clearing a fog a little bit I'd like to
offer a clarifying image of what
masculinity is actually supposed to be
and how it is supposed to act in the
world this is a story I've mentioned a
couple of times on the show but it's
worth mentioning again
um in in this situation it comes from
surgeon Houston's uh Gulag archipelago
his magnum opus about the Soviet labor
camp system
and one of the volumes volume one I
believe
he recounts the story of a man who had
been arrested on trumped-up charges and
shipped off to prison and when he was at
prison he was sentenced to death
but by the time the sentence had been
handed down his wife was already on a
boat on the way to visit him
and so he begged the guards to delay his
execution for a few days so that he
could see his wife one last time they
agreed
on the condition
that he doesn't tell her about his
impending execution
and he didn't he was with her for three
days never mentioned it never hinted at
it
and once she left he was taken
immediately before the firing squad and
shot
now that is stoicism and manliness
beyond the capacity of most mere mortals
but
it it points Us in the in the direction
that we should be striving towards
we are meant as men to carry our burdens
with dignity
and not to expect everyone else
least of all the women in our lives to
lighten our loads by always sharing in
them
that at least is one way to be a man
the other is Adam Schiff
weeping like a school girl
using his tears to manipulate and
exploit
you could choose that option if you want
but you have to sacrifice your dignity
and your masculinity and your
self-respect in the process does it make
sense that the same company who controls
half of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home big Tech is more powerful than
most countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big Tech and
that's why I use expressvpn think about
how much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit video you
watch message you send gets tracked and
data mined but when you run expressvpn
on your device the software hides your
IP address something big Tech can use to
personally identify you so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
harder to sell to advertisers therefore
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers that are on
your network what I like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use you
can download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and that's it
you're protected expressvpn does all
this without showing or slowing down
your connection that's why it's rated
the number one VPN service by techradar
The Verge and countless others so stop
handing all of your personal data over
to the big Tech Monopoly who Minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the VPN that I
trust to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
the next day
thank you
as I mentioned yesterday I tweeted that
men should not cry in public because
it's dishonorable and unmanly
though I allow for certain exceptions
which I have outlined in further detail
in the past
um perhaps I should publish an official
list you know with an index and a
glossary and a bibliography and
everything so that any man if he's
considering crying can quickly consult
the rule book and find out if he's if
his upcoming sobbing fit meets the
requirements you know is this going to
be sanctioned crying or not
but that's a project for another day for
now I can tell you that people have been
very very very upset
about this ironically thousands of men
have cried publicly over the fact that I
said they shouldn't cry publicly
there have also been some unexpected
voices chiming in to castigate me
including one of one of the guys from
Blink 182 which was funny and speaking
of funny there have been lots of
responses like this from a guy named
Andy ostroy who described himself as a
filmmaker and a proud Democrat he said I
Cry I Cry often and I'm more man than
you'll ever be
now it's not often that you hear someone
unironically use the phrase I'm more man
than you'll ever be and you certainly
don't hear it said right after the words
I cry often
but these are the kinds of landmarks
like Landmark occasions that Twitter has
made possible and we should be grateful
for that I should note that some of
these crying men have made physical
threats including a guy named Ronnie
ficaro some kind of musician
and he said quote I don't know who the f
you are but I don't like you at all
actually I'd love to punch you in your
stupid little face and make you cry you
little [ __ ] boy toxic waste of space
immediately after writing that Ronnie
deleted deleted the tweet and blocked me
I'm gonna punch you runs away crying
now I have to say I have never felt less
threatened by physical threats
look it's
it's easy to Mock and make fun of these
people
um
and to point at them and say haha you're
crying
and and uh and frankly it's a lot of fun
and we should do that
but what I'd really like to respond to
are the accusations leveled repeatedly
of me over the past two day or two
that I only say things like this like
it's dishonorable for men to cry in
public because I'm trying to shock and
offend someone actually called me a
shock tweeter which incidentally is how
I describe myself on my resume
shock tweeter
is that true though do I say these sorts
of things merely to cause shock and
outrage and defense
um the answer is yes
at least partly
the first reason that I say what I say
is that it's true and it's always worth
saying true things
but I am aware
that a statement like the one I made
about crying in public will provoke a
reaction I know that
I say it anyway not in spite of the
reaction it will cause but yes partly
because of that reaction
the point is not simply to selfishly
profit off of the outrage mob's anger
though that is one perk that I quite
enjoy the greater point is that most of
the things I say including the idea that
men should usually refrain from crying
in public
that's all that is really being said
here usually men should try not to cry
in public
that's it
these are completely Common Sense
completely unobjectionable things the
kinds of things that if I had said at
any other point in history in front of
almost any other audience anywhere
people would have yawned and said well
yeah what's your point
it would have seemed utterly obvious to
almost everyone who has ever lived
and yet now we're supposed to believe
that these obvious Common Sense
statements are not only wrong but absurd
outrageous insane I've actually been
been accused of insanity literal
Insanity for saying that men shouldn't
go around crying all the time
we can think of many other Common Sense
statements that provoke this kind of
reaction a statement like for example
men can't get pregnant that will even
shock people in medical school now
or or women are weaker than men
plenty of other examples come to mind
it's not simply that the mob will
disagree with these claims now
it's that they will treat the claims as
outright lunacy
they will react to a man speaking common
sense as if he is a raving maniac
and this tactic is extremely effective
because after a while
if you're not careful you're going to be
browbeat into thinking well if everyone
thinks that the idea is that offensive I
must be wrong
but you're not wrong you you have not
only rationality and Logic on your side
and common sense but the near Universal
consensus of all mankind until about 12
seconds ago
only now
you know is it that you're you're not
supposed to say those things anymore
and that's exactly why I say them
the more that people scream
and cry in the face of normal
inoffensive statements the more I will
say them
the more we should all say them
simply out of principle
and because it's true
and because it's funny to see you so mad
two days later
[Music]
I had a segment on uh with with Laura
Ingram on Fox news last night I don't
know if you got a chance to watch but if
he didn't get a chance you should go
find that segment somewhere and watch it
because it was really important uh I was
brought on to talk about the issue of
men crying which has been a a theme on
this show this week something I've dealt
with repeatedly and it it's great that
I'm I'm always brought if I'm if I'm
doing a cable news hit you know it's
going to be the important issues that's
what they bring me on for abuela men
crying like that's there's something
really important going on that's when
they say we need to get Matt Walsh in
here to talk about this and uh so I did
appreciate that and it was you know I
thought it was a worthwhile conversation
um
just on that note I you know you already
know I've talked about the the tweet
that I sent out where I said mention
crowds unmanly and undignified and
that's what a lot of what has sparked
this reaction from people and it hasn't
stopped yet it has the outrage mob they
have not usually
like I've been through this many times
and I've got the mob coming after me on
the internet
um and the reason I don't get upset
about it like so many people do well I'm
used to it it's also funny and who cares
what these people think
but I also know
um that the mob usually about 24 hours
like if it really bothers you what
they're saying which it shouldn't then
put your phone down for a day
and you go live your life well all these
people are obsessively messaging you I
hate you so much and you don't usually
it's 24 hours this has been we're going
on like three days and they haven't let
up
uh and so many of the responses are just
so funny I cannot recommend highly
enough if you want to entertain yourself
just put something out on your own
social media channels about
how men shouldn't cry because the
responses are unintentionally hysterical
I want to just share one more with you
okay this was uh someone last night
after my Fox News head
uh this is a woman
and here's here's what she she uh said
to me she said
Widow baby can't handle your feelings so
you'll stuff them as a therapist I like
to encourage people to express their
emotions in a healthy way a man crying
in public means he's very sure of
himself and comfortable with his
feelings what does that say about you I
love everything about this starting with
Widow baby
little baby can't handle your feelings
as a therapist I disagree with that
you're a therapist and that's how you
talk to to people
I would almost respect that I I've never
been to therapy a lot of people say that
I I should probably go
um but I would really respect I guess a
therapist where you sit down and you
start
telling them all your problems in your
life story
and they go oh Widow baby are you upset
about that your childhood trauma Widow
baby you want some tissues
so I thought that was pretty great um
although
Widow baby can't handle a feeling so you
stuff them but are are babies renowned
for stifling their emotions is that is
that what babies are all about
that hasn't been my experience with
babies
are are very bad at uh at controlling
their emotions and cry constantly
my whole point is that men should not be
like babies
that is my radical suggestion okay
so if you're looking for a therapist uh
maybe I'll I'll try to put you in touch
with this woman here